مو جزء الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اعلنت هيئه الكوارث والطوارئ
التركيه وقفه جهود البحث عن احياء تحت
انقاذ الزلزال المدمر في اغلب الولايات
باستثنائي كرمان مارش هذا وبدات السلطات
التركيه في بناء منطقه اقامه مؤقته
بمنطقتي نورداغ واصلاحيه في غاز عنتاب
ستستوعب 19000 شخص
هذا وتعهد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
كل ما بوسعها لمساعده في جهود الانقاذ
والاغاثه وكنب لينكن قد تفقد مع نظيره
التركيه الوضعه في المدن المنكوبه التي
اصابها الزلزال وبشان الوضع في سوريا
بالمسؤوليه عن تقييد دخول المساعدات الى
البلاد
نشرت صحيفه بلومبرج مذكره دبلوماسيين تقول
ان مراقبين الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
رصدوا في ايران ايرانيوم مخصبا اقل بقليل
من المستوى المطلوب لصنع سلاح النووي ذكرت
صحيفه ان الوكاله الدوليه تحاول تحديد
الكيفيه التي وصل بها اليورانيوم المخصب
الى درجه النقاء بالنسبه اربعه وثمانين في
المئه
من جهته قال المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
لطاقه الذريه ان الوكاله على علم
بالتقارير الصحفيه الاخيره عن مستويات
تخصيب اليورانيوم في ايران وقال ان
الوكاله تبحث مع ايران نتائج انشطه
التحقيق الاخير انها ستبلغ مجلس محافظي
الوكاله على النحو المناسب
من جهته قال المتحدث باسم منظمات الطاقه
الذريه الايرانيين ايران لم تتخذ اي اجراء
لتخصيب اليورانيوم بالنسبه تتجاوز 60%
واضاف ان وجود ذرات لليورانيوم المخصبه
بنسبه تتجاوز 60% هو امر طبيعي اثناء
عمليه التخصيب
بدورها كذا وزير الخارجيه الايراني في
اتصال مع منسق السياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي نو بحث معه والعلاقه بين
ايران والاتحاديه الاوروبي وخطه العمل
المشتركه بين ايران والوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
اعلنت وزاره الصحه السوريه سقوطها خمسه
قتل بينهم عسكري
واصابه خمسه عشر بقصف اسرائيلي على احياء
سكنيه في دمشق وطلبت الخارجيه السوريه
بتحرك دولي لوقف الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه
من جهتها نفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه
وجود ايرانيين بين ضحايا الغارات التي
استهدفت منطقه كفر سوسه في دمشق
وبينما التزمت اسرائيل الصمت ولم تعلق على
الهجوم قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه ان
بلاده لن تسمح لايران بامتلاك سلاح النووي
او التمركز قرب حدودي اسرائيل الشماليه
بحسب قوله
اكد البيان الختامي للقمه الافريقيه على
تفعيل منطقه للتجاره الحره كمشروع
استراتيجي في القاره وقال رئيس مفوضيه
الاتحاد الافريقي عدم الاستقرار هو التحدي
الاكبر وان الاتحاد يركز على تمويل عمليه
جديده لحفظ السلام وعقل انه اجراء اخراج
مسؤوله اسرائيل من افتتاح القمه لانه لم
توجه اي دعوه لمسؤولين اسرائيليين مؤكدا
ان الوضع اسرائيل كمراقب معلق منذ عام
[موسيقى]
انتهى كنت طابت اوقاتكم بكل خير